[Música]
momento de hablar de economía aquí en
directo américa en france 24 me acompaña
en el estudio horse hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches vamos a ampliar
información sobre ese buque que ya llegó
a las costas turcas cargado de toneladas
de granos ucranianos santiago ese buque
representa cierta esperanza también para
la crisis alimentaria global turquía que
es mediadora en la salida del grano
confirmó que el barco razón y ancló con
seguridad frente a la costa de turquía
embarcación lleva 26 mil 527 toneladas
de maíz con destino al líbano incluso
cerca de la frontera del bósforo desde
el mar negro unas 36 horas después de
haber partido del puerto ucraniano de
odessa según el ministerio de defensa
turco se espera que este miércoles el
centro de coordinación conjunta de
estambul donde trabaja personal ruso
ucraniano turco y de la unión de la
organización de naciones unidas
inspeccione el barco aún queda 27 barcos
en los tres puertos ucranianos cubiertos
por este acuerdo de exportación las
exportaciones de grano pretenden ayudar
a aliviar esta crisis alimentaria
mundial agravada por supuesto con la
guerra bueno hablamos de otra crisis y
nos vamos hasta españa porque llevan a
tener que limitar el uso de aire
acondicionado
factores sumándose hace plan de la unión
europea para limitar las importaciones
de gas ruso todo esto de cara al
invierno boreal esta medida afectará
comercios e instalaciones públicas y
también algunos medios de transporte en
estos lugares la calefacción deberá
mantenerse en un máximo de 19 grados en
invierno y a un mínimo de 27 grados en
verano según anunció la ministra de
transición ecológica teresa rivero en
los edificios públicos también tendrán
que estar apagados cuando no se utilicen
y las medidas estarán vigentes a partir
de la próxima semana estas nuevas
medidas obligan a los locales con aire
acondicionado o calefacción que reciben
al público a cerrar sus puertas para
evitar el derroche el bloque de la unión
europea se comprometió a hacer todo lo
posible para reducir su consumo de gas
en al menos un 15% entre agosto de este
año y marzo del próximo año incluso
instaron al sector privado a volver al
teletrabajo escuchemos un poco lo que
desde ahí la ministra
un tele trabajo que nos permita
concentrar los horarios la presencia
ahorrar en desplazamientos ahorrar
también en el consumo térmico de los
edificios fuimos capaces de hacerlo
durante la pandemia y desde entonces
hemos aprendido mucho hacemos a temas de
américa latina' en colombia la comisión
de empalme del gobierno entrante dijo
que van a recibir un país completamente
endeudado cómo está el panorama y en
color y con un déficit fiscal según
ellos en estado crítico según este
equipo del nuevo presidente gustavo
petro estiman un déficit fiscal del 5 6%
del producto interno bruto para este año
mientras la deuda pública rondaría el
56,5 por ciento del pib el gobierno de
petro prepara un proyecto de ley para
elevar los impuestos a los más ricos y
mejorar el recaudo con el objetivo de
financiar su ambicioso programa de
reformas sociales precisamente estas
reformas son delicadas en un país que
registra una inflación anual del 97 por
ciento el desempleo en 11,7 por ciento y
la pobreza que alcanza el 39 por ciento
de la población escuchemos que decía
este equipo
la reforma tributaria que cursarán el
congreso a la república con carácter
prioritario
se nos convierte en una
de forma imprescindible para llevar a
cabo la propuesta de gobierno vamos un
poco más al norte en eeuu los
empresarios publicaron menos ofertas de
empleo durante el mes de junio así es
las ofertas de empleo en ese país se
redujeron a 10,7 millones en junio
frente a los 11,3 millones de mayo estas
ofertas que nunca habían superado los 8
millones en un mes antes del año pasado
tocaron un máximo de 11 millones y
recientemente todos los meses desde
diciembre hasta mayo de este año el
mercado del trabajo ha sido resistente
en lo que va del año y las empresas se
quejan porque es difícil cubrir los
puestos vacantes los empleadores se
agregan mensualmente casi medio millón
de puestos y el desempleo está cerca de
su nivel más bajo en 50 años
precisamente esa es una de las razones
por las que muchos economistas creen que
la economía de eeuu aún no está en
recesión pese a estos dos trimestres
consecutivos en negativo bueno pasemos
ahora a las bolsas cómo les fue a los
principales parqués alrededor del mundo
empezamos en wall street que terminó a
la baja tras una sesión bastante agitada
sobre todo por las tensiones
geopolíticas que se agudizaron atrás de
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi a
taiwán en europa las acciones también
cayeron por estos temores de
desaceleración económica y las tensiones
entre la visita de pelosi a taiwán y en
américa latina la bolsa mexicana de
valores cerró en terreno negativo por
las mismas tensiones geopolíticas ya que
eeuu es el más importante socio
comercial de méxico- y china por
supuesto el principal proveedor del
mundo porque muchas gracias por este
reporte punto final en la economía vamos
a hacer una corta pausa aquí en directo
américa de a continuación el debate
[Música]